what's going on everybody it's Jake and
welcome back to another Elden ring
discussion video today I'd like to talk
about what it means to be Elden Lord and
if given the chance who would have been
the better choice to claim that title a
while back I asked you guys who is
already the best Elden Lord the choices
I gave were between Godfrey radagon
Placida sax and yourself by no surprise
most of the votes went to ourselves
being the best Elden Lord and as funny
as this is it actually has some truth to
it we did go on to defeat all of these
previous eldenlords in a fight so based
on Godfrey's own words on what it takes
to be Elden Lord we really are the best
choice
Brave tarnished
life strength
befits a crown
the only argument I see with this is
that we aren't really fighting these
previous Elden Lords at their full
strength when we enter the picture
radagon seems to be used as a puppet by
the greater will his body is quite
literally breaking away trying to hold
the fragments of the Elden ring together
and while still a difficult fight I
don't believe we're fighting him at his
strongest same goes for Placida sax
obviously he's lost three of his heads
in his battle against Godfrey and is
only capable of existing in a realm
Beyond time to keep him from fading away
completely which is very similar
thematically to radagon the more I think
about it with radagon holding the Elden
ring together the greater will had to
call back the tarnish to the lands
between who collect great runes to mend
the Elden ring of these many tarnish
called back this obviously includes us
and Godfrey the first Elden Lord who led
the Long March of the tarnished after
they were banished from the lands
between by Queen America in America's
own words
my Lord and thy Warriors I divest each
of thee of thy Grace With Thine Eyes
dimmed ye will be driven from the lands
between ye will wage war in a land afar
where ye will live and die now I'm not
sure if Godfrey is limited with his
power when we're fighting against him
obviously sirash is holding back Godfrey
from becoming his true warrior self poor
Lou but Godfrey takes care of that
problem leading into the second phase of
our fight with him there could be an
argument made that he isn't as powerful
as he once was the opening cinematic
depicts horalu skewered with swords
Spears and what looks like him being
crucified with the guidance of Grace
between him and sarash Awakening him
from his death in what looks to be the
Badlands outside the lands between
however this is exactly what queen
America wanted Godfrey and his Warriors
to experience during their banishment to
grow stronger then after that death I
will give back what I once claimed
return to the lands between
wage war
and brandish the Elden ring grow strong
in the face of death Warriors of my Lord
Lord Godfrey this is likely where
Godfrey was in between us defeating
morgot burning the ERD tree releasing
dust and death and coming back to the
base of the earth tree he was awakened
by grace and called back to the lands
between Justice America foretold he then
finds morgot defeated next to the throne
and he looks down in remorse towards his
Omen Sun realizing that he had been
running the show as the last of all
Kings of Landell since no one else in
the family would be able or willing to
take that responsibility his son Fades
away in his arms revealing A New Path of
Grace for Godfrey to follow which points
directly at us it's actually beautiful
Godfrey was banished for losing his side
of Grace or losing his ambition to fight
and Conquer All who oppose their order
because he had defeated everyone that
needed to be defeated I cannot think of
a bigger motivation to fight than
looking at the person who killed your
son the greater will needs the strongest
to take the mantle of Elden Lord who fix
what has been broken now all that is
left is to determine who is the
strongest Godfrey or you and we all know
how that ends at least if you made it
that far in your own playthrough I still
think it's amazing that it can be
inferred that if a player has given up
on their playthrough meaning they had
stopped playing the game before
completion out of frustration or
whatever it is then that tarnished
character can be seen as just another
failure in the cycle of things another
hollowed pathless tarnish that had given
up on their guidance and didn't live up
to the expectations that were put on
them never to reach their full potential
that was the case in the Dark Souls
games and really is no different in
eldering I absolutely love that aspect
of these games now let's think of a
different scenario let's say all of
these past Elden Lords were out of the
picture when I asked you guys the
community who you thought deserved to be
Elden Lord between morgot and radon the
votes were close but ultimately landed
on General radon receiving the a
majority out of almost twenty thousand
votes this vote actually sparked an
interesting debate and honestly at this
point I'm not even sure who I'd choose
morgot is obviously the most devoted
demigod to the golden order in the most
tragic of ways since birth morga has
been shunned by his family and the Very
order he chose to follow banished to the
sewers below the city to live out the
rest of his life with the rest of his
fellow Omen so that he couldn't blemish
the perfect family image he was born
into even so morgoth created his
alternate Persona Margate and leads the
knights Cavalry to find and deliver
death to great warriors Knights and
champions who might defy that order he
tries to stop you many times from
obtaining a great Rune because he knows
why the tarnished have been called back
to the lands between and he knows godric
likely isn't powerful enough to stop us
it's kind of sad how A Shard Bearer is
mostly seen as a pathetic madman even by
those who follow him he had an ugly
heart an ugly accoutinance and met the
ugliest of ends eh
morgot created this alternate Persona
because in my opinion he hates himself
he hates the name morgot and the blemish
that that name holds on his family the
Thrones
[Music]
stained by my curse such shame I cannot
bear thy part in this
shall not be forgiven I made a video
called like father like son that goes
over the fates of both morga and Godfrey
over a year ago now I believe that video
still holds up and is one of my favorite
videos I've ever made so you should go
check it out if you haven't already in
short morgot would never stray from the
order as eldenlord he cared for it even
after he was treated like an outcast in
Monster by his own family even though
based on his father's reaction to his
death not everyone thought he deserved
the Fate that he did suffer all he
wanted was a family but since he
couldn't have that even with his own
Omen twin brother he became what his
lost family needed a king that wouldn't
stray from its ideals no matter what
morgot likely using his alternate
Persona as marget was clearly a
Powerhouse during the shattering War
even besting a younger much smaller
radon in battle in obtaining his own
powerful great room during this war
morgot tries to stop us on our journey
at every turn because he knew we would
cause a major change in the world that
he finally had some power in eventually
he finally Falls to us and comes to the
realization that we are all going to
fail in our mission
oh yeah
we are all
forsaken
none may claim the title of Elden Lord
I Deeds shall be met with failure just
as I now let's talk about General radon
the proclaimed strongest of the demigods
during the shattering War this Fortress
houses only the vanquished that when the
stars align
a wall Festival honoring the last battle
and death of General Redan the mightiest
demigod of the shattering and bearer of
a great Rune unfortunately radon is no
longer the powerful General he once was
as we know he has been infected with the
Scarlet rot after his epic battle with
Melania he has now lost his mind and
wanders what was once the caled Wilds
eating corpses of Fallen friends and
foes and howls at the sky like a dog
before this radon was a powerful Warrior
that seemed to idolize Godfrey during
his time as Elden Lord radon's golden
armor has depictions of Godfrey's lion
Regent sarash and while I doubt radon
followed the golden order fully I do
believe that he idolized that power that
a warrior can portray through battle
just as Godfrey did on his tear through
the lands between to defeat all who
opposed what they believed in as we
discussed earlier a crown seems to only
be worn with strength strength is the
key to becoming eldenlord and radon has
no shortage of strength born from the
queen of sorcerers raised in the academy
and trained by all bastard Lords in the
town of Celia Rodan mastered gravity
magic to a point of being able to hold
back the literal Stars themselves
powerful enough magic that even Ronnie
couldn't break his spells he was also a
great leader inspiring his men so much
that they stayed in caled to continue to
fight against the rot that has infected
their land and has driven their once
great General to Madness I haven't
mentioned this in a long time but radon
is still my favorite character in the
game to this day my video going over his
story last year is the most successful
video on this channel because it really
is an honorable story I still remember
Elden Ring's first story trailer that
showed us the battle between radon and
Melania during the shattering War I
can't get over the scene where radon
allows Melania to put her prosthetic arm
back on before it attacking her this
shows radon's confidence in honorable
nature in battle even during an all-out
War where everything that they know is
in a complete state of chaos walking
into red main Castle is amazing
listening to a choir of rodan's men sing
in unison to celebrate their General and
hopefully give him what he wants which
is just an honorable death at last
the war Festival has ended Brave
Champion you have our gratitude
celebration was spectacular
General radarn is surely pleased
festering with rot and crippled by
Madness all he wanted was an honorable
death also I know everyone already knows
this but the fact that radon refused to
give up his horse Leonard even when he
started to grow into his giant frame and
mastered gravity magic the hover
slightly over his horse is still just so
adorable to me it shows that he cares
deeply for those that follow him all of
these actions indicate a strong leader
that culminates a presence that clearly
many people wanted to follow in the
footsteps of even if radon doesn't even
have feet at this point I think both of
these demigods are deserving of the
title of eldenlord for all the reasons
that we have discussed today but we
already know that it only takes strength
to claim the crown so just like our
fight with Godfrey they would have to
fight each other to determine who is the
strongest again we can get a glimpse of
that in the opening Cinema attic and it
looks like to me that morgot had the
advantage over radon during this battle
but of course Verdon isn't at his full
strength at this point it's a required
challenge for the strongest to fight
just like it is between Godfrey and us
so I think it's a coin flip who would
win this fight my bet would go to radon
even in his infected state of mind again
you guys seem to feel the same as we
discussed but if you feel differently
after watching this video let me know
down in the comments that's all for me
today thank you all for watching
subscribe if you want to and I will see
you in the next video take care